team spirit we're not supposed to be a
ti
a team of rookies isn't supposed to be
in the grand finals of dota's biggest
tournament you were expecting fire the
international is one of the most
prestigious tournaments in esports where
history has been made time and time
again
[Music]
but at ti-10
these russian underdogs did more than
just make history
they did the impossible
they're ready to close it this time only
two left can they stop a piercing
other than a
find my
all right folks before we get into team
spirit's incredible story i just want to
make sure that you're all sub to the
channel so please if you haven't done it
already hit that sub button and turn on
notifications it really does help anyway
if you've ever watched the international
you've seen plenty of cinderella stories
from historic upsets to full-blown
miracle runs ti is one of the most
unpredictable tournaments in esports but
team spirits run a ti 10 was something
special even by ti standards why well
for starters they shouldn't have even
been a ti to begin with after putting up
decent showings at esl one germany dota
summit 13 and epic league their then
unsigned stack known as yellow submarine
was picked up by team spirit while most
orgs were leaving dota due to financial
stresses created by coven
vernon
led by their manager corbin spirit's
roster was basically a grab bag of
random underdog players they were a way
for a mid-sized org in a long-suffering
region to take a calculated
cost-effective risk
swami team spirit premier company
so who were spirit well for the most
part
nobody at least nobody of note like i
said they were mostly hungry untested
up-and-comers the first was toronto
tokyo and yes that's really his name an
aspiring mathematician who dropped out
of moscow state university to pursue a
career in professional dota next you had
yotoro a 17 year old carrie who played
well beyond his years and collapsed a
mechanically gifted offlaner who despite
his limited hero pool never miscast a
spell this was a new generation of cis
talent who were desperate to test their
medal on the big stage of course in
order to do that they need leadership
direction and some sort of veteran
presence and that's where the only
member of this roster that your average
dota fan had heard of comes into play
the drafter and fifth position support
miposhka as one of the best captains cis
dota had ever seen maposhka circled in
and around the top tier of competitive
play for years as the leader of team
empire they're waiting to try to turn
this he's got black hole ready he's
gonna pop
there it is black hole onto three can
they get anything else with this they
got the wallet on the omnislash vacuum
coming in crystal they've lost three
will they lose more no tails in trouble
his armament will not stay the miracle
will try to tp out but he won't make it
an empire turn it into a five-man wipe
what a black hole for me posh you've got
to be freaky kidding me his claim to
fame was securing a top eight finish at
his first ever international in 2017 by
eliminating evil geniuses while his team
played with a standout 2700 they find
the weapon as well it looks over for eg
and it is over team empire will 2-0 out
the former ti champions
that said spirit still needed a coach so
they enlisted the services of an even
more storied veteran one who'd been
around cis dota since the very beginning
silent the universe has no way out this
might be it right now they've lost three
gt
whole team empire claim
the land finals for the joint mlg pro
league so with all this promising talent
why did i say that spirit shouldn't have
even been a ti because they were
literally one map away from never even
qualifying to begin with you see the
easiest way for rosters to get into ti
is to earn enough points in the dota pro
circuit to get a direct invite
unfortunately spirit season got off to a
rough start they missed the singapore
major and from there
things looked bleak
in june with mira their new explosive
fourth position support income the
shackles mirror holds him in place and
the serpent walls pummeling eg into the
ground arteezy he's left here he's on an
island there's no one to save the teddy
bear no picnic for you and an absolute
slaughter they just don't have enough
damage gg
calling it the roster could synergize
and show tons of promise but they were
in desperate need of some confidence and
at the animager they found that spark
there's a faith beyond last ditch effort
with the manta side that's a lot of
damage can they kill him they do but he
does have blind back we'll try to get
back in as fast as he as he can as the
soul binders onto two faith beyond is
gonna tumble says three dead five versus
two psg lgd only left with a couple
supports and they're gonna call it gg
what a game from team spirit they
collapse there's the horn toss into the
skewer s4
he will not have buyback for this and
yeah he drops 70 seconds on the deck and
team spirit
looked to be taking this in
a gaben level shellacking i have to say
cinder and this is a mega stop there is
the rp
not even getting the warlock old off
does have buyback but it matters not gg
alliance is eliminated and team spirit
shall move on unfortunately spirit got
knocked out in the second round of the
lower bracket their season was over they
had no chance of getting a direct invite
to ti their only hope was to win the cis
regional qualifier it was a close call
but spirit managed to eke it out in a
five map grand final
oh the stone it catches two
what a connection yataro jumps in never
a chance team spirit makes the play
finds the kill they're going to ti trent
and they are going to be very happy
about it indeed going into ti itself
spirit were a bit of an unknown quantity
sure they could be explosive but they
were also extremely young and
inexperienced people had almost no idea
what to expect of them especially since
they were apparently one of several
smaller rosters that weren't even given
suitable space to play
the cis region has always been a dota
powerhouse navi won the first ti and for
years after virtus pro always looked
like one of the best teams in the world
heading into the tournament and yet
they always choked needless to say hopes
weren't high for a cis roster made up of
almost entirely rookies spirits started
the group stage by losing three of their
first four matches it looked like they
were crumbling as if their unlikely run
would end right there
and there is no buyback on that map
collapse he's trying to tp up and indeed
the cookie puts a stop to the escape
collapse is gone he knows mirror and
they'll call it
goodness gee meanwhile the tiny is still
dealing with this racer collapses
receiving no help from his supports
whatsoever because they are being
demolished and countered by the cores of
psg lgd yatara gets out
razer gets out toronto tokyo gets out
but they call gg it's just over kyle and
they have so much collapse goes down
they don't manage to finally finish up
yeah he gets taken out and they'll chase
after the rubric that gg gets called
spirit has had enough because
the confidence
yang trying to hang on to anybody gets
bashed by collabs gigi is going to be
called yotora might have gone for it a
little bit too much before but now it's
just the right amount the ravage comes
in but it does not delay it does not
stall it will not end this nightmare for
fanatic they had this game but now
they're going to lose it to team spirits
does get into that invest form a witness
curse though three heroes surrounding
chris luck nullified again the necro
just not accomplishing anything on east
coast
not a chance in that game
incredibly one-sided team spirit taking
the 2-0 victory over bc the cis squad
managed to win every match for the rest
of groups narrowly making it into the
upper bracket it was exactly the chance
they needed to make a deep run
but then they threw it all away
gg and the key
take game three in a very convincing
fashion
that means that they will be top six
guaranteed now cinderella we don't know
who they're gonna play obviously since
this is the first upper bracket best of
three but team spirit they're still
alive that's the important thing for
them if spirit wanted to win the
tournament they would need to make a
truly historic lower bracket run an
anime power-up for the ages they'd need
to beat everyone with no safety net
team spirit no more messing around with
them as they focus down the throne
one by one by one as death will die
and more to follow as team spirit is
gonna close this one out
oh gee there's nobody left alive it's
only no tail there's nothing left and gg
is called team spirits
end of the game taking down oh gee
what a cinderella story here on the main
stage
he stands no chance
gg is called as team spirit knocks vp
out of the competition
a spirit they're going to close it up
james he's going to go in for one last
try for the jumpsuit for collapse
straight
[Applause]
that's a huge curse on the three heroes
as team secret gets rp from collapse and
the right clicks aren't there from
yataro triple kill my head
making an ultra kill
will he get another rampage at ti 10.
absolutely yataro does it again cinderin
they're gonna call gg the underdog story
is still alive team spirit move on to
the grand finals
somehow spirit had clawed their way
through every juggernaut in the
tournament and now
they were in a ti grand final
controlled
there was only one opponent left psg lgd
the chinese superpower who steamrolled
their way through groups in the upper
bracket and were all but guaranteed to
hoist the aegis of champions but then
spirits started playing bkb from army
he's trying to stay on charging tourism
to sing their way back to safety and now
he's ready to go back in the song ends
toronto tokyo bkb up john pogba with the
round and grabs make the answer army
disappears in a matter of seconds she
killed a ball as well gg is called
and my goodness what a buttery smooth
stuff to the ground finals in the team
spirit another huge win team spirit they
won't be denied the fort toss catches on
this eq and yarrow just slaughter the
way they play these fights they're so in
sync with one another
they call it a cinderella story well
it's a shoot that's wearing it
going into game three it seemed like
spirits stunned their opponents into
submission but this was lgd they weren't
going down without a fight
it's just coming down
he's in the mountain and it is
[Music]
turns now on to the ancient hot out
afterwards where's the fight i'm not
seeing it going definitely so far they
turned that little wide just grip to the
side oh they kept going to collapse wise
not dying nobody's dying
they already fall again as gg is called
23-3
a statement from lgb heading into the
fifth and final game
spirit looked like they were done it
seemed like their miracle run momentum
was spent and lgd was finally on their
way to claiming the aegis but somehow
spirit brought it back
again
lincoln john collapsed he's got his eyes
on him still no nothing to say or why
for 50 seconds he's alone he's gone in
although that was a risky move he's got
the back of a shin queue
but spirit look at the trace on slide
chase he's gone
they're ready to close it this time
only two left
can they stop at psg
lgbtq's got his own
[Music]
[Applause]
despite the realization that they were
about to win 18 million dollars they
kept their focus and closed out the game
ti is no stranger to cinderella stories
but what spirit did a ti 10 was truly a
miracle what a story what a road what a
dream here to then achieve the spirit
of the ages
ladies
the cis region loves dota but it had
been a decade since they took home the
aegis and they spent years watching
their greatest hope lose and lose again
by bringing dota's biggest trophy home
spirit brought their region to its feet
like never before hell even the
president of russia vladimir putin
issued a congratulatory note from the
desk of the
kremlin
after two years of watching dota
flounder the unlikeliest roster made us
all remember why it's so special and
it's hard to imagine a better way to
bring it back
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tech talk